if you are saying he can't do his job
because of his race is that not the
definition of racism I don't know but I
have a judge who is a hater of Donald
Trump the hater he's a hater his name is
Gonzalo Curiel the judge who happens to
be we believe Mexican
we're building a wall he's a Mexican
we're building a wall between here in
Mexico no Mexican judge could ever be
involved in a case that involves you
he's a member of a society where you
know very pro Mexico and that's fine you
know to a 5:1 ask you about comments you
made about the judge in the Trent
University case you said that you
thought it was a conflict of interest
that he was the judge because he's of
Mexican heritage even though he's from
Indiana and he said no I want this mr.
case and she doesn't have to be the like
let me get his hair I'll tell you what
it has to do something you're calling my
accused himself because he's then you
also say does he know the lawyer on the
other side that's another that's another
problem and you're invoking his race
when talking about whether or not he
could do his job I'm building a wall if
you are saying he can't do his job
because of his race is that not the
definition of racism
this is one of the worst mistakes Trump
is made and I think it's inexcusable
first of all this judge was born in
Indiana
I think his comments were racist
claiming a person can't do the job
because of their race is sort of like
the textbook definition of a racist guy
I think that should be absolutely
disavowed it's absolutely unacceptable